um thanks for having me
um i'm going to talk about happiness
and about making our css happy and
give me a few minutes to to tell you
what i mean with that
um i'm a bit unsure about my audience
today i had very very detailed questions
around lunch
um so i've tried to not
dive too much into the details but also
i don't want to make it boring so do
give me feedback early enough um your
css
do you guys know whether your css is
happy uh or if it's sad
or maybe worse
really really broken you guys know this
this is the asset
test sa2 test this is ie7 it might be a
bad example
but i wanna what i wanna say is
um do you guys are you guys really sure
that the css you're developing
is looking good and i like to just see
hands who are you guys
are you guys really confident that what
you're developing is really looking good
on all browsers can i see some hands
who's very conf who's confident who's
confident just
basically confident that it's working
well what he's developing
somebody over there so there should be a
bit more people around here right
because we're all professionals and
we're building customers clients people
for our work
um so it's kind of sad
it makes me happy because it kind of
motivates what i'm talking about today
so we users when we visit websites
um we find out about problems right we
see them
um and that could be something very
simple um see facebook or github
as an example where there's a weird line
break happening um stuff like that we
it looks kind of unprofessional um but
we can work with that um and there's
worse problems like
uh something hovering over my elements i
can't even see what's happening
uh or maybe my pop-up i don't know if
you can see that with the red arrows
over there
my whole um my whole pop-up is not
really
showing so um that was that's not
something i want
um or um thankfully
uh elliot this morning um is
playing with the twitter feed um he
added
a unicode 200 to sorry 22e which is
um forced right to left writing
control code in unicode everything that
follows our character
forces the text to be rendered from
right to left sounds stupid but if you
write arabic for example
which is a writing system from written
from right to left this is a usual
useful function
where if you put it into your username
so the elliott cable's username is
that unicode character plus the string
then everything behind that
is in the in the wrong order so you see
a
elite table and css conf
retweeted you um just wrong direction so
i say
do they really want to have that i think
twitter should fix their uh
their problem um i think i think that's
a problem and they might not even be
aware of that
so um and to tell you one story of my
past
i've been on teams where i kind of
inherited the front end role
i don't believe in roles i think we
people should
have multiple abilities but in some
teams
they were like old-school developers
you're going to just be the front-end
guy
well old-school developers um are good
they have all their testing tools they
know what they're doing
on the team i went on i had to do the
css and the html and i kept
it kept breaking all the time and nobody
found out
it took some time it was not i don't i
don't believe it was because i was bad
it was just i didn't have
the tools for the job to make sure that
stuff i developed was still working two
weeks later with somebody else changed
something
so what i think what's kind of missing
is uh safety net
um i hope i kind of motivated why we
need something like that i showed you a
few
few examples where it breaks this was my
revelation after a few weeks on the job
it's like i don't have a safety net all
my other developers have a safety net if
they write java they have tools
and basically css exists um since
forever and we don't have
so far don't really know how to test it
talking a bit about being professional
um it's a bit loaded term
um what i want to say is um
we all i think all people sitting here
do want to you guys want to give maximum
um uh you want to do the best and give
the quality the best quality to your
clients and customers
but css is getting much more complex by
the year we're adding more features
luckily where we're very happy for
colors
and and hsv and stuff but it's getting
more complex we are we now have
responsive design that means
um that mobile phone that tab that
computer um the pages are getting
uh larger and smarter and nicer more
devices and multiple browsers
i don't know how you guys do do that but
if you change something do you guys
visit
all the 20 devices that you should look
good on possibly not
and even if it might break any time and
it you won't
possibly recheck every every time
testing testing is a solution to that
problem
software developers have had tooling for
a long time
i'm kind of sorry i'm very bad at
sketching my handwriting is awful
but what i want to show here is
a very example web stack maybe you guys
have something similar
there is a ui on top it's written in css
html there's some javascript that does
something that rearranges the dom does
something
and there's then client logic below that
does some business logic maybe still in
the browser there's several logic
maybe written in node.js and for the
more sophisticated websites there might
be an engine x
server sitting below and mongodb
database or whatever
we want to test that if you're sitting
on a team with 120 developers
and you need to release frequently and
you have a million visitors per
per day and we i think i'm working on a
big
eshop in hamburg they make a massive
amount of money every every day
if something breaks you can see we have
all those graphs and suddenly
you deploy you go live and suddenly the
order drops and management management
comes in and says
we're losing money by the minute that's
why
we're using we as developers we're using
the tools um
can i so there's selenium as an example
can i ask can i see hans
who is using selenium or knows what this
is
okay um that's that's a fair number so
selenium is basically just
a browser um tool for the ones who
haven't heard
just a tool that takes a browser and
clicks through things and
allowed to formulate assertions other
other ways of doing it is writing small
granular unit tests
what i what i finally found out was
there is no there's nothing i i believe
there's nothing
that really helps me with exactly that
thing css and html
um i could i could start writing
selenium tests that make sure that
the color of that button is blue but if
you guys
have if uh the guys who are here uh who
have written selenium it's an it's an i
can't say anything bad about it because
it was kind of
started by my company that i work for
but it's an awful tool to
to write very fine granular things
it's more for functional aspects for
what the user wants for the user journey
what you want to test
there is no tools for for that
but um why am i telling you all this
because there is a way
um since one two years ago um there were
a few people starting to look into that
problem
we now realize slowly that there is a
problem that needs fixing
and there are some solutions to that and
to motivate
how such a solution could look like i
want to show you a tool
um start with one and maybe give you a
short overview what else is out there on
the market
i hope by now that you guys kind of
agree with me that this yes
it is bad i want to know what's going on
and if i if i break something
accidentally i want to find out about it
so
simple demo that's a button
it's a button i styled it um it's just a
black
border one pixel has some width the
bigger text
that's just my my application that's
just my my html and css i want to test
this is a very simple css testing
solution i'm going to talk about it
later on a bit more just i want to
describe what you see here
this is the button that you've seen
before rendered that's a screenshot
there is um it's yellow because it says
this test
is still not defined basically i have a
rendered screenshot
what i now need to say for that tool to
work to do its job i need to say
this is the image that i want to keep
so the tool works in such a way that you
take a screenshot
and you fix it uh you say this
screenshot is the target i want to keep
that and if it breaks
do tell me this is what i'm going to do
so i'm just going to click that
green button here and i just now set
that image to be the true image and if
it changes
do tell me if i reload the page i don't
know if you guys know jasmine a testing
tool it kind of it's kind of inspired by
jasmine where you just open the browser
and
rerun the test so there you go um
that's a very easy trick right i just
clicked the button now it's green
i'm not sure whether you guys believe me
so i can i can break that test
so i can re run this it's going to be
green
sorry sorry to the cameraman who now has
to refocus for me it's just going to be
very short
um
i keep using shift for that but it
doesn't work in sublime um
yeah do one job um anyway so i'm going
to
change the border from please don't
laugh at my css i'm really
really bad at css that's why my slides
are all in in white and black
um so i'm going to change that to yellow
um auto save enabled i'm going to rerun
the test
i'm pressing command r there you go the
tool finds out that something has
changed
um what it does it gives me a diff image
that's one way of rendering there are
other ways but that's
it just gives me a black canvas and says
here's the that's the area
um that has changed those anything
that's not black has changed
and if you see here the current page is
yellow although the board is yellow
that one is black so this tool helps me
to quickly find out where something
changes
i think that's the start so what do we
do right now
i have a red test the test says this
this is not going to go to production
you have to do something about it
so let's say the yellow border was not
intended i'm going to just revert my
change
there you go screen again um so
this is this tool now allows me to be
notified whenever something
changes it's it the test can't tell you
whether it's good or bad it just says
something changed can you please uh have
some manual intervention here and tell
me
how i should proceed so let's do an
intentional change let's say
um the background color for example
so if i'm going to go to yellow here
sorry for the audio i think
around here it's a bit bit too loud
trying to be a bit careful
there you go i changed the background
from white to yellow
the color blue stems from there is a um
math.apps calculation
and it just um uh blue is just the
difference between white and yellow
apparently
so let's say the yellow is the improved
design that's version two
and um i was told me as a developer i
was told
to please make it yellow so i need to
tell the tool there you go
accept this re-render and we're good to
go and if i hover over this
you can see it now has the yellow button
so that
is a very very simple tool and a very
simple way
of giving you kind of a safety net and i
i hope that is very
very clear right now the screenshot is a
very simple way to tap into my css it's
not just css there's html involved
it gets more complicated when there's
javascript involved but that's doable
but it gives me a way of tracking
changes now
um i'm so lucky that i'm not the first
uh the first to
doing the first talk today because it
was very the first one but nicole was
very interesting to me
she described working on a project where
they needed to
change the ui nobody trusted the
existing implementation nobody felt they
were up for the job
and i had some similar experiences
although not in that big
big range if you have such a tool
it could support you uh moving over to
something without a rewrite for example
um so i'm definitely going to to start
doing um what nicole was talking about
this morning
but i still want to have a safety net
this one could help you
provide you something around refactoring
you could add some tests change the code
make it nicer
but still have the output the same and
this tool will tell you it's looking
good
so so what um
we can check we can check the changes in
css um
screenshots is the solution used here
tests
don't tell you that something broke
they're just a change notification and
basically what the tool does is you
don't
need to do manual testing on all
your um html you don't need to go
through all your pages and look at
everything
if you have tests for the important
paths it's going to tell you what you
need to look at
so it kind of boils down down to once
the developer changes something
um he or she should then check whether
the tests are still
green and if not maybe generate a new
reference image so i'd say a much leaner
way of moving forward and rechecking
those things are working
so the tool i just showed to you is
called css critique
i'm a bit biased because i'm the guy
behind that
it's a very very simple tool um the
motivation is
make it dead simple to start off it's
basically just an npn package you just
install it
and the idea is use the browser who is
the browser is the software that renders
screenshots why can't i just do the
testing tool
in the browser and i can get the visual
feedback in the browser
so for me as a developer it's the
quickest feedback i can get
there are other smart tools um so wraith
for example
i'm not sure whether it's the correct
pronunciation it's it's a
i think the scottish word for ghost
um wraith um is um
is done by the bbc news team who have a
very special problem the bbc news team
they have change in content all the time
every second there's some more things
happening
in the world um and what they need to do
is
um when they deploy still make sure that
their content is the same but they can't
so i just showed you static images
before right i fixed an image and maybe
it's going to stay the same for a year
but with bbc
because their content is changing they
have other problems so what they are
doing is
they just have a pre post deployment
before they deploy to live with a new
solution
um they are using a staging environment
taking a screenshot using the life
environment and see what changes so the
person who who clicks the deploy button
or who needs to go through that 20 pages
reference for deploying an application
um needs to uh can has a handy tool
of finding out what changes so i think
um
that is a very very um i like the idea
behind that it's a very very smart move
for very specific problems that they
have um
then there's phantom css um i personally
describe phantom css as the entry drug
to css testing
um because if you guys know selenium um
phantom's css is basically just similar
it's using casper js
you guys know maybe know that on
phantomjs what you do is you tell
um phantom which is a headless browser
to go here click there
and then if the correct state is there
take a screenshot
similar to the other two solutions it's
working on screenshots
phantom css is done by the huddle team
they have a kind of different diffing
image
but um basically if you look down here
that's sorry it's a bit too small
that's the syntax how how they work you
just
sorry um no that was wrong
um it's basically just click through the
page click on elements and once
you find a state that you want to test
you take take a screenshot
um but like selenium there are other
solutions
um i don't want to spend too much time
on this um
because there's a lot a lot a lot of
things one interesting thing might be
the hardy hardy by simon who's sadly not
here today
i think he was planning to talk to which
i'd love to hear
hardy is different that it doesn't do
screenshots
it does allow you to test your
single elements on the page instead of
taking a screenshot you do tell me
whether that h1 element still has font
size
15 or something so it's a very different
way of doing that and there are
a lot of different solutions um and if
you're interested in that
um simon runs this webpage csste.st
css test there's a long list of tools
and content and examples
um that's an awesome resource to start
to start with
um i've used it last year on a project
so
my problem is i work on different
projects over time i'm not staying very
long sadly this is with
the company i'm working with but i've
used it on the three-month project
it was a greenfield project we needed to
deliver after three months the time was
fixed it was going for the
chess championship um we didn't have um
we didn't have any time to we couldn't
you know shift it
it had to be fixed for that for that
date and
um we managed um to deliver without
visual defects
we had a safety net um i could tell any
every commit was tested and you could
quickly see whether something changed
and it worked pretty pretty well for for
me and the team
um what was interesting for me you can
drive out your ui tests um through
um through that i don't know if you guys
um
i i had to work on a on a shopping
basket um which was very complex you had
to
add elements to the shopping basket so
whenever i needed to touch the shopping
basket and change the shopping basket
there was like oh i first have to put 10
articles to find that edge case where
there's t10 articles and
there needs to be what some button that
says more or something
that was very awful to set up all the
time i don't know how you guys deal with
that problem
but if you first define a test case with
that come up with
a mock html structure then you can just
uh
iterate on uh on the test and come up
with a screenshot and that's way
faster to develop something than just
start up your server and add some stuff
to the shopping basket in that example
um screenshots seem to us
a bit crazy right um if you if you ask
um
if if you ask old-school developers it's
like screenshots
can't be a valid testing tool it's like
we test by values we test that something
has value
we test that the http uh return code has
value 200. um
and screenshots do have a problem they
are they can be flaky so
we see how that problem is in news um if
you have changing content the screenshot
changes all the time and you don't want
to be bothered by changing content all
the time
you only want you want to have the test
go green if if nothing changed you don't
want to be
you know annoyed by testing over
changing content um renderings
at the second point are unique
snowflakes um
my browser renders different than your
browser um
you even if we have the same firefox you
might have font installed that i don't
um you might uh work on a newer mac
edition with a different font and
rendering engine in the back
so you can't even you can't use the
pages to to
to cooperate with your uh the guy next
to you on the team
so there are some problems that still
need some solving um but i think
it's ready for prime time um when i say
there are different solutions
go find out what works for you guys
um i have 10 minutes left um i think we
also would be happy to
start up with the next talk earlier um i
had
some very particular questions before so
i don't know whether
um that was all boring because you heard
about this before there were some talks
last year about this topic
um i was hopeful i i wanted to give like
a
short introduction into that topic some
motivation i'll show you one tool
um and i could go into more details but
maybe you guys have some questions
you can throw everything at it so the
question was does it need to be single
elements
you can throw everything at it you could
basically throw a whole web page at it
in that case but you i don't think you
would like to
so we're starting a star guide questions
about star guide and including that into
the test and i think that's the this
brilliant idea
because i wouldn't add the whole style
guide page
um to to the test i would create a
single test for every element in your
style guide
so you know exactly what breaks but yes
um so that's that's basically where i
came
that's where i started off i was asked
to create a style guide and that was
like i built a test page and i thought
that
test page isn't that beautiful i can
exactly see um if something changes
i don't have to click to the shopping
basket on page 10 to find out
and then i thought why do i why do i
have to check it i'm bored i'm easily
bored and i need the computer to do that
for me
and yeah um
so i don't know whether there's any of
that solution is doing cross browser for
now um
so you definitely can't take the
screenshot from firefox and compared to
chrome
especially because you might have
different fallback features what is
there's a new feature in chrome you'd
like to support but firefox doesn't it
doesn't do it
yet or vice versa there are the
renderings are going to be difficult
and as i said they're snowflakes so
there is a problem with that and i don't
think any of those tools tackle that
but then i i have limited knowledge
about that but that's i think that's
definitely something you could go into
in the future and it's something we
should tackle
because i think that's one of our major
pain points i would even say that my
software sometimes goes live without
somebody checking that in ie9
do you have a question sorry fine um
yes so um i'm a bit so i just gave you
um
what i just showed you was um the tool
i'm developing um
which is that one um to give you an idea
how how that would look like
i don't know if you guys know the to do
mvc application which is an awesome
application
demo application to test different um
nvc tools for javascript
um this is my vision of how our unit how
i would
test the ui for that and
to answer your question um what i what i
had was
um we have uh with the project i was on
we had three big
build monitors on the wall we didn't
even know what to show on those monitors
so what i did was just open a browser
like that put it on that monitor
and every time a test failed i logged in
uh by accession and clicked or something
like that it's
still kind of not the the goal where i'd
like to go but
it's something that that was useful and
if you have a monitor
if you have ui tests which are
inherently uh visual
it's good to have a monitor to show you
what changed uh unlike having some weird
output saying like
your screenshot does not look the same
anymore because that's the only other
option that you have
um and so just to show you some some
examples i'm a huge fan
that's maybe a bit more details um that
i was asked about around lunch there are
a lot of other tools
for example i didn't talk about i think
it's called depicted which is just the
uh a lot the proper pronunciation for dx
oh sorry d x d d p sorry whatever um
and it's using um an in a very
it uses an algorithm to find out what
whether it renders differently
from a perspective um what i'm trying to
solve
is pixel uh pixel by pixel comparison
what i want to do is you might call that
crazy but i want to do
i want to have the test complaint when
one single pixel changes one hue
one shoe step um it's very there's a
very
very very easy answer to that this
rendering here
is 800 times 600 pixel if somebody asked
me to underline the last
uh the last line this is 200 pixels and
max
200 pixels time 1 pixels is 200 pixels
square
area 200 pixels in an 800 600 pixel
image is
nothing it's not even one percent so if
i have an algorithm that kind of
is fuzzy and most of the other tools are
doing fuzzy compare comparison
because you guys know anti-aliasing the
pages look different all the time
so i'm going um that my personal pet
peeve i'm going for pixel perfect
comparisons and if there are problems
around that with flaky test i'm going to
find a different way of solving that
sorry did i answer your question
so a question about travis ci um the
problem i haven't solved is the command
line
and that's something that needs solving
um but that's the way i'm i'm
good doing it takes much more time
phantom css and that's the benefit of
that
um is i think you can do it add it to
travis i haven't
i'm talking to a guy who's implementing
phantom css on the project i have five
minutes left i think
um the the problem with phantom css is
um again the snowflakes um i i tried it
i have a mac computer i tried to check
check in a build on a linux server yeah
that didn't work well
um there was uh same browser same
version but the browsers
depend on the font rendering engine of
the the system below so good question
sadly no so far
so um phantom css is using phantom um
if you want to know what i'm doing come
to my talk on friday
i i lost a year
implementing uh that in the browser
um the browser is not very happy with
you rendering
other pages in inside the browser but
there is a way um if you guys interested
i can go on forever
thanks a lot